the woman accused of killing her
seven-year-old son and dumping his body
near mountain springs will face a judge
for the first
time bianca holmen live this morning
outside the courthouse downtown with the
story bianca
[Music]
good morning john 35 year old samantha
moreno rodriguez is waking up in jail
in just a couple of hours she will be in
court facing charges
that she murdered her son and dumped his
body
so this is how it all began this all
started may 28 when hikers found the
body of a seven-year-old liam husted
off of a hiking trail near state route
160. with the help of police in
california metro detectives determined
maria rodriguez took houston from their
san jose home four days
earlier leaving behind the boy's father
metro says she left a message saying
i'm going to try and get a house for
liam and i
we can talk about this in the future
vacation when she left san jose
that she was intending on starting a new
life
mariano rodriguez was arrested june 8 at
a hotel in denver
she waived extradition clearing the way
for her return to las vegas earlier this
week
moreno rodriguez will face a single
count of murder in this case and so
today's court appearance is actually a
warrant return hearing that's where
someone is arrested in another city and
then returned here to clark county of
course we'll be in the courtroom to give
you the latest
reporting live from downtown las vegas
bianca holman 8 news now